so you're hsbc one of the biggest banks
in the world you are so big and powerful
that if you were a country you would be
the fifth biggest world power outranking
the united kingdom
see the great thing about being a bank
is that everyone needs banking services
moms dads terrorist drug traffickers
sketchy shell companies everyone the
problem is countries don't like it when
banks work with people they deem as
criminals so as a bank with the power of
a country you're presented with two very
different paths on how to operate path
number one you properly vet every client
and refuse to let criminals use your
bank thus leaving money on the table or
you can take path number two you happily
work with terrorist drug traffickers
illegal diamond dealers and other
sketchy characters because they are your
biggest customers they deposit giant
sell some money which you can then use
to lend out charge transaction fees on
to make even more money
so hsbc which path do you take
american authorities discovered that the
sinaloa cartel moved 881 million dollars
through hsbc accounts said hsbc had made
a string of errors including inadequate
monitoring of money laundering and
terrorist financing scenarios hsbc's
compliance history as examined today is
unacceptable
[Music]
as a drug cartel you have a big issue on
your hands you're making loads of cash
billions upon billions of dollars now
that may not sound like a problem at
first but cash is bulky one billion
dollars weighs around a thousand tons
and that's only if it's all in a hundred
dollar bills
so you would need a giant place to store
all that cash security to protect it
from these security to make sure your
own workers don't skim any of it and
it's kind of hard to make purchases in
general with just cash though you can't
buy anything online with just physical
cash you can't buy anything overseas
without shipping a bunch of physical
cash over there it's just a mess
so the easiest route is to just deposit
your blood money into a bank the problem
is most banks follow know your customer
laws and don't let criminals deposit
money hsbc is not one of those banks
when joaquin el chapo guzman was
operating the world's largest drug
cartel out of sinhala mexico he was
doing most of his banking through
europe's largest bank hsbc american
authorities discovered that the sinaloa
cartel moved
881 million dollars through hsbc
accounts as bank officials turned a
blind eye to the illegality in 2002 hsbc
acquired battalbank with the intention
of building a bigger presence in mexico
but taobang also just happened to be the
cineloa cartels financial institution of
choice el chapo had enormous sums of
money flowing into it but i'm sure that
had nothing to do with their decision to
buy it anyways hsbc had their own system
of scoring how risky a bank was the
lower the score the safer the bank is
and riskier banks are given a higher
rating even though there are literally
piles of evidence showing that
battalback was handling huge amounts of
dirty cash from mexican cartels hsbc
gave them the lowest possible risk
rating in other words hsbc bought a bank
filled to the brim with cartel money
gave them a low risk rating to make it
look legit so they could collect fees
and interests on the hundreds of
thousands of dollars i rolled in daily
from the cartel here's how hsbc and
mexican cartels would help each other
first drug traffickers would take their
dirty money to mexico where the hsbc
bridge would happily process the
millions without question then hsbc
mexico would send the money off to a
corresponding branch in the u.s who
would route the funds to the ultimate
destination all of this was possible
because they knew the transactions
wouldn't get flagged and even if they
were flagged the money would still be
sent through without further
investigation
once mexican cartels realized how much
easier hsbc made their lives they went
all out
to make the deposit process more
efficient cartel members even started
bringing cash in boxes that were
specifically made to fit through the
hsbc teller windows hsbc was building a
reputation with cartel lords as they
placed along their money but bank
officials completely ignored it because
they were rolling in profits but this
couldn't go on forever without their
crimes being noticed
giant corporations like hsbc have always
had to jump on us when it comes to
investing because they can't afford the
hedge funds and dedicated money managers
while we're left to figure everything
out for ourselves this did not sit well
with some people so they decided to
bridge the gap by creating titan today
titan is already managing 750 million
dollars for over 35 000 clients just
like you titan is an investing app that
allows regular people like you and me to
have their funds managed by investment
experts who keep you updated along the
way it gives you access to an
award-winning investment team in the
palm of your hands with zero performance
fees no lockups and a flat rate advisory
fee all you have to do is download the
app sign up and deposit a hundred
dollars and boom you have access to some
of the best investment strategies out
there from usb stocks to crypto assets
since its creation titan has
outperformed all the major indices and
robo advisors using their unique
strategy of identifying compounder
stocks and holding on tights and it's
not just another etf or mutual fund with
titan you always know exactly where your
money is because your team explains
every move they make with real-time
video updates all it takes is a hundred
dollars to start so if you're ready to
start taking advantage of titan's
award-winning strategies and experts go
to titan.com to get three months of
asset management without any fees that's
titan.com jake for 90 days free thanks
to titan for sponsoring this video
meet el chino a businessman in the drug
trafficking scene he ran a wholesale
pharmaceutical company in mexico called
unimed since uni men dealt with
pharmaceuticals they were legally
allowed to bring all different chemicals
into mexico and many of these chemicals
could be used by cartels to make their
drugs and thus a criminal partnership
between el chino and el chapo's cartel
was born unfortunately his pharma
company failed to renew their license in
2005 which led to police raiding el
chino's home in mexico city that's where
they found over 200 million us dollars
piled up waist high this led police to
discovering that all this money was
being deposited into hsbc then the whole
image came together once investigators
looked into hsbc more they realized that
it wasn't just el chino who was taking
advantage of hsbc's relaxed
anti-laundering regulations there were
lots of people el chino was just the
beginning by 2010 the occ which monitors
the u.s banking system had heard enough
they issued a 31-page order detailing
the money laundering that was happening
at hsbc this letter was meant to serve
as a warning to hsbc while also giving
instructions on how to fix their
problems one of the things the bank was
told to do was to go back to the backlog
of around 17 000 suspicious activity
alerts that they had spent years
ignoring this was a massive task for
hsbc so they started hiring a bunch of
random people to fill in these
compliance officer spots and go through
the backlogs the compliance officers
found many transactions from people on
the olfac sanctions list a list that
outlines all the people and
organizations that companies are not
supposed to do business with like
terrorists and traffickers usually the
names on the sanctions list are
automatically prevented from making
transactions so why were they going
through hsbc well hsbc was using dots
and dashes to conceal the name of anyone
on the list for example if kim jong-un
was trying to wire money through hsbc
hsbc would write his name like this
or like this
that way it would bypass the automatic
system and allow the transactions to go
through it's honestly kind of funny how
brazen they were with this once this was
uncovered the united states knew it was
time to take action against hsbc or at
least that's what everyone thought was
going to happen
[Music]
as part of its resolution of these
charges
hsbc has agreed to forfeit
1.256 billion dollars for a total
recovery of over 1.9
billion dollars
after years of shady dealings everything
came to a head with hsbc in 2012. they
were called to a hearing with the u.s
senate's where the senate said most of
the 7 billion dollars in banknotes hsbc
transfer from mexico to the us came from
drug dealing they also stated that hsbc
went out of its way to bypass the
automated systems that blocked
transactions with terrorists drug lords
and countries on america's naughty list
like hiding 19.4 billion dollars worth
of transactions with iran by december
2012 u.s district attorney loretta lynch
announced that criminal charges have
been filled against hsbc for laundering
at least 881 million dollars for el
chapo's cartel and other mexican drug
cartels all this meant that justice was
about to be served right wrong
immediately after announcing the charges
the da explains that hsbc will receive a
deferred prosecution agreement or dpa
which is kind of like putting a giant
corporation on probation a slap on the
wrists hsbc admitted to helping mexican
joy cartels funnel money and the dpa
required hsbc to pay a fine of 1.9
billion dollars the largest penalty of
its kind that a bank had ever received
but in reality 1.9 billion dollars was
equal to five weeks of the bank's
profits hsbc also needed to be watched
by an independent monitor for the next
five years while the monitor was
supposed to keep an eye on hsbc they
were also selected and paid for by the
bank plus monitors weren't law
enforcement officials they didn't have
that much power and hsbc knew this the
public was outraged the decision
confirmed what everyone already knew the
big banks are too big for jail but they
aren't jailable end quotes throughout
pages of reports the appointed monitor
explained how hsbc was still providing
financial services to suspicious people
and organizations by 2017 the five-year
monitor requirement came to an end and
it was announced that hsbc had met its
obligations and no longer needed the
monitor hsbc just got off the hook for
working with mexican drug cartels
without a single executive getting
arrested
it's been a decade since hsbc was
charged so has enough time passed for
hsbc to change their ways nope
in 2015 journalists from around the
globe released a swiss leaks report
about how hsbc was helping wealthy
customers at their swiss unit evade
taxes mr galva will get on a lot faster
if you give a straight answer to a
straight question you agree with me it's
caused reputational damage to the bank
yes are you the appropriate person in
those circumstances to remain as the
chief executive officer of hsbc
i believe i am because my tax affairs
are in order that scandal settled for 40
million euros which equal to 0.1 of
their revenue for that year more
recently hsbc was exposed by the fincen
files in 2020 which were a collection of
leaked us treasury documents from the
financial crimes enforcement network or
fincin the files reviewed hsbc's deep
involvement with a ponzi scheme called
wmc777
it also showed that hsbc's compliance
staff filed reports that lacked basic
customer information on show companies
that process almost 1.5 billion dollars
in transactions turning a blind eye to a
sketchy customer base a classic hsbc
move in interviews with former hsbc
compliance officers they said that the
bank's anti-money laundering program was
a complete joke even during its
probation period hsbc started as a bank
that connected britain and china
together in hong kong today they've
evolved into one of the most widespread
financial institutions in the world
bigger than britain itself where on top
of being too big to fail they're also
too big to jail
you